en un emotivo discurso desde atlanta yo
bailé en reiteró que la democracia está
en peligro porque los republicanos y el
expresidente trump están tratando de
cambiar las leyes electorales a nivel
estatal para ganar las próximas
elecciones el ex presidente quiere
quitarles la opción de voto al que no lo
apoya afirmó bardem en referencia a las
leyes estatales que impulsan los
republicanos y que limitan el voto por
correo y la votación de estudiantes y
minorías entre otras medidas al respecto
vall d'en afirmó que apoyará el cambio
de reglas y la eliminación del famoso
filibuster en el senado para proteger el
derecho al voto si es necesario es decir
que tratará de acabar con la medida que
le da potestad al partido que es minoría
en el senado en este caso el republicano
de requerir 60 votos sobre 100 para
aprobar cualquier tipo de leyes en este
caso sería la aprobación de la ley john
lewis para prevenir la discriminación en
el voto dándole también potestad al
gobierno federal de revisar las leyes
electorales estatales y también para
aprobar la ley de libertad de voto que
asegura la posibilidad de voto por
correo y el voto por adelantado lo
complicado es que aunque se logre acabar
con el filibuster y los demócratas
puedan pasar estas leyes con mayoría
simple ni siquiera es seguro que se
pongan de acuerdo los demócratas para
lograr el margen de 50 votos necesarios
para aprobar estas leyes electorales a
nivel federal